Speaker 1: Legal expert Glenn Kirschner says
that failed. Former President Donald Trump is
potentially facing 25 years in prison based on
the potential criminal referrals that he is up
against. We are going to listen to him, explain
it himself. There's a good Newsweek write up
about it. Trump may face 25 years in prison and be
blocked from future office less of office. Let's
listen. This is Glenn Kirschner on the Joy
Reid program on MSNBC. Remember, nobody here
is saying Trump is going to prison. We're talking
about based on the crimes Trump may be charged
with. What would the potential sentence be?
Speaker 4: A referral doesn't mean they're
prosecuting. They don't have a power to do that.
Speaker 3: But would such a referral at least have
sort of value? Even if they.
Speaker 4: Can't get
get it all the way to closure.
Speaker 2: It will have value. You know,
the Department of Justice prides itself on
exercising independent prosecutorial discretion,
but they can't turn a blind eye to a co-equal
branch of government that has done such an
exhaustive investigation. When they pass all
of that evidence over to DOJ and they recommend
criminal investigations and prosecutions. And
here's the thing. It's great that they're talking
about obstructing official proceedings. That's a
20 year offense. It's great that they're talking
about conspiracy to commit offenses against the
United States. That's a five year offense. But
the important one, Joey, is the one you mentioned
insurrection. Why? Because the available sentence,
if you're convicted of insurrection, unlike those
other charges, is that you shall be prohibited
from holding office under the United States.
That, quite frankly, is the one I'm rooting for.
Speaker 1: And of course, it continues to
be stunning that not only can Trump run
for president, he is running for president,
even though the campaign so far has been a
complete and total flop. Now, let's be very real
about what I know many of you consider to be the
most important question here. Do presidents get
indicted in the United States? Could a president
get indicted? Why has a president never been
indicted in the United States? Let's start the
conversation with a reminder that no president
has ever done the things Donald Trump did. Put
that aside for now, because we want to talk now
about historical precedent. To put it in one word,
tradition is the reason that presidents have not
historically been indicted by the Department of
Justice. And what I mean by that is historically
out of the principle of executive immunity,
which holds the president is not subject to
criminal prosecution while serving in office.
The DOJ has not pursued charges against a
president. And the principle behind that is,
if you charge a sitting president, you inhibit
their ability to do the job of being president of
the United States. And if a president worries that
what they do might get them indicted while they
are president, they might act other than how they
believe is in the best interest of the country for
fear of a personal prosecution or because of
the distraction of a criminal trial. However,
after leaving office, there is nothing that
would prevent or preclude a president from being
investigated, from being potentially charged with
crimes and from being prosecuted. Importantly,
you also have impeachment. Impeachment for
high crimes and misdemeanors is a completely
separate process from criminal prosecution and
doesn't require any crime to have been committed.
Important to understand that the January
six committee investigation and potential
criminal referrals would not be for impeachable
offenses because the House could handle that
itself. Trump's out of office. He's already
been impeached twice. This is about in their
investigative carrying out of their investigative
role. The House may come across what are apparent
crimes and refer those to the Department
of Justice. Tradition is the only reason
why historically you have not seen prosecution
of a President Trump is now out of office. We
may know within hours whether the House committee
says Trump's on the list of people who committed
crimes. Here is a criminal referral. We may
know within hours or a day or two. And then
the question will be, what does the DOJ do under
Merrick Garland? Merrick Garland has said things
like Trump running for president wouldn't get him
out of jail. But it's not a get out of jail free
card. Fine. But he is not expressed that his DOJ
actually has the testicular fortitude, for lack
of a better term, to really charge Trump. So we
will see and we will find out very, very soon.